hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comet today we are in a
game number eight of the 2016 World
Chess Championship between Manish
Carlsen and Sergey karyakin so far we
played seven games we've had seven sighs
a few pretty exciting games Magnus
Carlsen few chances probably could have
won but all in all there's definitely
been some games that didn't last very
long
we're not that exciting in my opinion
but game number 8 Magnus Carlsen has the
white pieces gonna be looking to really
take the advantage in this match with
only five games remaining including this
one so he definitely wants to make sure
he comes out strong he only has the
white pieces a few more times in this
tournament
Sergey caveat can playing the black
pieces he's trying to hold strong here
he's been playing defense most the
tournament hasn't put too much pressure
on Magnus Carlsen so he wants to just
continue doing that fill in his opponent
out if anything they can get to a
tiebreaker
after 12 games and they get to some
blitz and rapid game so I think all in
all Sergey catkins game playing is
pretty solid Magnus Carlsen starts out
with pawn to d4 not something we see
very often usually gonna be seeing that
pawn to e4 now we did see Magnus Carlsen
start the tournament game number one
with pawn to d4 which was very odd and
then Bishop to g5 but that didn't last
too long it was a pretty exciting draw
if you remember game number one but pawn
to d4
I'm Knight f6 Knight f3 pawn to d5 and
then pawn to e3 so opening we don't see
very often pawn to e6 and then Bishop to
d3 so getting into kind of the the Col
system pawn to c5 a pawn here to b3
getting ready to think of it as Bishop
here to be 7 and then Bishop to e7 now
if you kind of look at the main line of
the Col system usually it continues with
Knight to c6 trying to control the
server of the board getting your Knights
out before bishops a lot of times you'll
hear that said in opening theory castle
on the Kings side
Bishop to d6 centralizing that Bishop
Bishop to b2 could try to control the
dark squares in the stern of the board a
castle on the King set but magnus
carlsen changed up a little bit and said
i'm gonna go ahead and play Bishop to e7
first castle castle Bishop here to be 2
and then from circa caddie Atkins
standpoint he really would like to bring
his knight involvement to the game you
usually want to
nights control the staring of the board
but he recognizes that eventually wants
to play pawn here to be six solidifying
the pawn chain since this pawn chain
right here on f7 e 6 + e 5 are blocking
his light squared bishop he's probably
not gonna be bringing his bishop here
eventually he wants to play pawn here to
b7 or b6 and then bring his Bishop here
to b7 so knowing that he has some
options for his knight he could play
Knight here to d7 Knight here to c6
which would be a very common move but he
wants to give himself some flexibility
depending on how magnus carlsen is
continue if you man discard some plays
Knight here to c3 you'll probably see
something along the lines of Knight here
to c6 but he decides to wait and play
pawn to b6 just giving him that
flexibility wait to see what his
opponent does Magnus Carlsen decides to
go and take on c5 Bishop recaptures you
can't see this symmetrical line from
sort of get karyakin with his pawn
structures and he's been playing this a
lot of the tournament it's kind of what
he seems to be very familiar with very
comfortable with as far as defending
especially on the black side so all now
didn't expect too much different from
cardiac in Knight here to d2 and then
from that Bishop to b7 trying to control
the light squares getting more material
in bulbs to the game Queen here to e2
can completing the development from
Magnus Carlsen and the Knight to d7 as
we discussed before he did have some
options good thing he waited he really
likes the night here on d7 this can
always just jump in action now that
there is kind of an opening here on the
c5 with a semi opened file he could
always bring this over to the Queen side
if he wants to start a big attack on
that side Carlsen continues with pawn to
c4 and in cardiac in here on c4 now I
thought he had some other options that
we may see on board I thought rook to c8
trying to control the semi open file I
thought that makes a lot of sense even
Queen to e7 completing his development I
think makes sense that's probably better
than you know Queen to c7 this doesn't
look as good because now if the pawn
takes on d5 when ciri capture all of a
sudden a rook to c1 pinning down a
spaceship can't really move can start to
put a lot of pressure on that pawn to c4
after you remove this defender on d5
just puts the Queen and too much
pressure
I just don't think cardiac and needs to
worry about that but he decides to go
ahead and take here on C for the night
recaptures Queen here to e7 so
completing his development as well
a3 just consolidating here on a b4 and
then immediately response from cardiac
and he played pawns who 85 and he does
need to make sure that he controls this
be for square he don't want your
opponent playing a pond to be for
forcing that Bishop back it is on a very
very nice outpost here on c5 and now why
can't play this pawn here too before you
just see the capture here and then the
bishop is gonna recapture that's clearly
gonna be bad for Magnus Carlsen so
correctly plays pawn down here to a5
night to a d4 centralizing rook over
here to d8 getting both the rooks
involved into the game rook here to d1
we're here to see Hayden and rook here
to see one so both sides kind of have
the the same mindset and they're just
kind of as you see the center of the
board they have a lot of material each
side two pawns off the board and they're
just kind of waiting for some fireworks
in at the center of the board
now the Knights gonna come back here to
f8 just opening up the door for the rook
here on D a to really hone down and
control the center of the board and you
may want to bring it over here to g6
start to attack on the King side if he
wants to Queen back here to e1 it's kind
of tough to figure out how magnus
carlsen is gonna continue in this spot
he could try you know pawn to h3 that's
not super exciting it does stop the
knight coming down here to g4 so that's
something but as far as where else he
really goes to I mean he could always
bring night to c2 looks like a
possibility opening up the door for you
know this rook to kind of control a
little bit more is Bishop's not gonna be
doing too much so all in all he played
Queen down here to e1 don't really think
he loved it too much I don't think he
has tons of options here Knight here to
g6 and then Bishop to FY now I'm not a
huge fan of Bishop to f1 getting your
queen and your bishop he is opening up
the door for his rook here on d1 to
attack but it seems a little
counterintuitive to be playing the white
pieces and then just retreat all of your
material back not a huge fan for Magnus
Carlsen but Knight here to g4 from
cardiac in night
b5 very nice square it's gonna be tough
to kind of kick this off can always have
an outpost if you wants to play pawn
here to a4 and you really don't want
your you have this double bishop pair
you really don't want to be doing
anything with this night with your
bishop so it's going to be tough
especially with your opponent's Knights
on the other side of the board Bishop
here to c6 attacking Pawnee r28 force we
talked about solidifying nice little
outpost for both of these nights and
then Bishop down here to d5 also
somewhat odd just to see the bishop
moving down here to c6 and then moving
to d5 it has some other options he
didn't have to play Bishop d6 he could
have played queen down here to g5 and
then you know maybe pawn to h3 forcing
the knight back Knight comes to e5 could
see a capture here Knight takes back on
e5 Bishop takes Queen here to e5 we have
Kuryakin with double bishop pair very
good board presence very active Queen on
board you have some passive material
back here Queen and Bishop back on the
first ring so I thought this would been
a nice alternative he decided to go and
play Bishop e2 c6 they mean you play
Bishop here to d5 so Bishop to a d4 so
both sides just get material back in the
stern of the board and then we start to
see some exchange the bishop takes on c4
rook takes Bishop takes rook recaptures
and then all of a sudden we do see some
exchange I think Magnus Carlsen probably
comes out ahead he's controlling this
area of the board a little bit more you
know if the rook were to come down here
and take he recaptures he has very good
board presence with his pawns
he has nice little outpost over here
with this knight on d5 he has the only
bishop on board which I think goes
extremely well with pawn structures on
either side of the board neither side
has the best Queen on board but all in
all I would give this a slight edge to
Magnus Carlsen Carlsen continues with
Queen here to d2 just getting in this on
a defiled make sure he controls that as
much as possible
we're cover here to a b8 just
maneuvering over to the Queens out a
little bit protecting this backward pawn
here on b6 pawn here to g3
Knight to e5 Bishop to g2 nice little
square from this Bishop your energy to
controlling
lot of the board can always centralize
it if it needs to but wasn't doing too
much on f1 now it is very involved into
the game pawn to h6 pawn up here to f4
so Magnus Carlsen being somewhat
aggressive aggressive starting to attack
on the Kings side might appear to a d7
Knight to a 7 and then the Queen comes
down here to a3 so trying really to get
all up in Magnus Carlsen side of the
board somewhat interesting to see that
so if he can start to to get some
material to help with that he could
start to have an attack but he is
attacking this pawn here on a4 we see
the knight come back here to c6
attacking the rook the rook Singh we
come over here to f8 and then pawn to h3
and I thought pawn to h3 was somewhat
interesting I think it's gonna be giving
up material he doesn't have to do he
does have some other options on board he
could take you know rook takes on d7
would be interesting Knight takes on d7
Queen takes on d7 we see capture here on
e3 King to f1 a g5 I think that this is
fairly interesting for white although he
has kind of an exposed King I think he
has a pretty good structure here but his
size instead to play h3 and then Knight
over here to a c5 so a great outpost
move for this night starting to as we
talked about maneuver material over to
the Queen side of the board starting to
put pressure on Magnus Carlsen
King here to h2 Knight to a5 so
capturing material up a pawn and
material on the board now a rook up here
to d8 so Magnus Carlsen says I'll give
up a pawn because I have a pretty strong
initiative to start to attack
we're compared to d8 pawn to g6 allowing
for just an avenue for this King to come
if he needs to queen up here to d4 says
yeah okay that defender and g7 was
protecting this night so I'm gonna go
ahead and attack that King here to g7
really need to hold on to that material
and then what I was kind of expecting is
rook here to d7 strong attack on the
square here on f7 the knight can't move
because it is being pinned down right
here Magnus Carlsen decided hey I only
gave it what pawn material let's give up
more material it plays pawn to sea
five don't like this move at all rook
takes on d8 Knight takes on d8 then all
of a sudden the knight recaptures here
on c5 outpost for this Knight nice
little square this Knight appears no
longer really doing too much really
needs to get back into the center of the
board really controlling stuff and black
has two pawns of material and they are
both passed and they are looking to be
pushed I think Madison Carlsen kind of
put himself in a tough spot
now Matt is crossing continues with
Queen to d6 and immediately we see a
certainty a Kennedy I can't give the
advantage back he plays Queen here to d3
I don't know if he was just expecting
Magnus Carlsen to immediately just take
here and then he could exchange and just
say hey we're going to the endgame and I
have to pawn advantage but Magnus
Carlsen does not want to do that all and
he's not going to instead he plays pawn
or excuse me Knight takes on the e6
check which is a extremely strong move
and after the pawn takes then Queen up
here to e7 King to g8 and then the
Knights going to fall and just kind of
gave that material back as we talked
about if we continue pawn here to 8th
for a pawn up here - to e4 Queen d7 just
taking more material all of a sudden
four pawns to four pawns no advantage at
all sit and think about how much
different this is if we were to come
back on board and say if we're here
instead of the Queen taking our queen
coming to d3 let's say he instead played
Queen to a4 okay Queen to a4 then all of
a sudden we have to see maybe pawn to g4
he can't really do that you know Knight
to e6 because then all of a sudden the
knight takes and the Queen never can
come down and capture that Queen it's
not there anymore so this is going to be
extremely bad so maybe we say okay what
if the Queen were to take on b6 okay
there's a pawn material he could take
then all of a sudden Knight to d7
forcing the Queen to move Queen back
here to a7 Queen up here to b5 Knight
here to c6 and then you start pushing
the pawn it's very tough
magnus carlsen to try to control that so
all in all I do think he gave that
material back after Queen to d3 as we
kind of continued with Knight takes and
then as we maneuver a little bit around
this is kind of where we stay in Queen
to g6 check cardiac can responds with
Queen to g7 says hey if you want to go
ahead and take my queen
that's fine I'll exchange it then I'll
go ahead and push my pawn down you can't
really stop it
Magnus Carlsen correctly decides that's
not the path he wants to take so Queen
up here - eh Queen here - f8 and says
hey let's let's try that again if you'd
like to manage Crowson says no thanks
Queen here to see six quid over here to
d8 spawn up to f5 so Magnus decides to
start pushing our own pawns that's the
only path if we are gonna continue
playing not try for any sort of
Perpetual check the best path to victory
is starting to push our own pawns that's
we does pawn here to f5 and then on the
the Queen side of the board if you have
a passed pawn rule number one
push that passed pawn rule number two
protect the pass pawn rule number three
continue to push the passed pawn so pawn
to e3 pawn takes here on e6 King here to
g7 paneer to e7 just gives that material
up and then a queen over here - b7 or b6
so it says okay I'll give up that pawn
it wasn't gonna do too much I didn't
have the material I really need to hold
on to that so I'm gonna give up that so
that I can take your pawn on d6 now I
have to worry about to pass pawns I just
have to worry about one over on the
Queen side of the board Knight down to
d3 so sir Kay Kutta yakun
this is a nice little interesting move
he's starting to put more pressure on
his opponent bringing the knight down
here to d3 really makes magnus carlsen
kind of sit there and ponder you know
how he's gonna continue he in his head
he knows this is a drum game but he also
doesn't want to mess this up for any
reason especially as since he has the
white pieces that would be a catastrophe
in the 8th game of this tournament so he
thinks for a while plays Queen here to
a5 attacking at this pawn here on a3
Queen down here to c5 says hey look
let's go ahead and exchange vanish
Carlsen again rightfully says no thanks
Queen here to a6 Knight to e5 Queen over
here to
six says I just want to stop this pond
from moving forward if the Queen moves
potentially start going to protect this
so nice little square pawn here to h5
and then Magnus Carlsen you know as far
as kind of where he moves from here he
has a few options I don't know that any
of them are amazing as far as how he
continues on board as far as finding an
attack I think he's definitely in
defense mode right now but he could play
you know Queen to a6 you know try to
hold on to it from there
that's one option he could try Queen to
b3 and just try to hold on from there
but he somehow finds a really terrible
move probably the worst move in the
tournament so far and he played pawns
heuh form what he didn't recognize is
that he left this square here on g4
vulnerable to the knight coming to g4
and that's unfortunate because Sergey
karyakin not too long after this played
pond - a - putting too much pressure
all of a sudden pretty much the Queen
has to take here on a2 but after the
Queen takes on a - then this game is
pretty much over and after pawn to a -
Magnus Carlsen actually resigned in the
game so play this out so you can see how
it may have gone if the Queen were to
take here on a - this would be the the
fastest lost Magnus Carlsen could have
Knight to g4 check King up here - h3
Queen down here - g1 and then all of a
sudden this Knight can't be attacked
we do have checkmate coming here on h2
so has to do something else
- Bishop to f3 getting out of the way
night down here to f3 or f2 and you can
see after check the queen is forced to
come over he's going to lose his Queen
it for some reason Madison wanted to
play a longer game and say let's play
quant or queen - a6 but then all of a
sudden Queen down here - f2 Queen here
to a3 Knight to f3 check King up here -
h1 or h3 Knight to e1 attacking the
bishop Queen over here to c3 remember
that Magnus Carlsen doesn't
your time always has to be aware that
the pawn can come down here to a1 so
there was a check a king over here to h7
Queen up here c7 eventually just can't
stop it Queen up here to f6 kind of puts
a stop to all that nonsense and from
here Magnus Carlsen just couldn't do
anything else but after a pawn to a to
Magnus Carlsen decided to go ahead and
resign so playing the white pieces in
game 8 we only have four games left
losses to sir da karyakin and there were
some some fireworks after this game
Magnus Carlsen was not pleased with his
performance and if you kind of heard
about the the press conference afterward
Sergei Kuryakin as you can imagine was
getting a lot of interviews before the
big press conference where both of the
players sit down with the press and they
answer questions so they kind of have
Magnus Carlsen sitting on stage at the
press conference by himself while they
were on the side interviewing surrogate
cardiac and madness cross and not too
pleased about that and stormed off and
somewhat odd fashion and was not present
for the press conference which I'm not
even sure if that's allowed by rules he
may get fined or something I'm not sure
a lot of people on social media talking
about how you know that's disrespectful
I'm not gonna comment on that but I will
say he did show up to the press
conference kind of had him sitting there
he was somewhat sad to see him sitting
there in misery and then did store him
off it was kind of odd to see him store
him off so although Magnus Carlsen very
very tough game in game number II but
congrats to Sergei cardiac in for
sticking in there playing a great
defense and then just slowly slowly
waiting for Magnus Carlsen to make a
mistake which usually doesn't happen at
all and then finding that right
opportunity that after pawn to h4 he did
find the correct line with pawn to a2 so
I think the rest of the games are gonna
be pretty exciting Magnus Carlsen I
don't think he's been putting his
opponent too many crazy positions I'm
hoping that after this it's kind of wake
up all this call that says your opponent
is no slouch he will win if you don't
try something different
Sergei cardiac in will easily win this
tournament
if we see the similar stuff that we've
seen up into this point so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this game I think the most
exciting so far we haven't really seen
the coal system played at high level in
a while and to see all these variations
and then to see at the very end magnus
carlsen lose kind of crazy so i'm
excited we have a game off our day off
and the Mount Magnus housing comes back
with the black pieces to defend on
Wednesday so everyone thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video